hi there steve kaufman here this is the
third
in the series of videos where i talk
about how stephen covey's seven habits
of highly effective people applies to
language learning
the third of stephen covey's habits is
to uh what he calls put first things
first now this is advice to a manager
and it means that if you want your
people to perform well you yourself
have to be proactive and have to be a
model that they can
follow he says that rule number two
begin with the end in mind is what he
calls the mental creation you've got
this idea of where you want to get to
and rule three is the physical that is
where you're going to actually make it
happen so
with language learning you have this
vision of what you want to be
where you want what level you want to
achieve
now rule three is you know put first
things first in other words make it
happen so
because
language learning
takes a lot of time do it every day or
as close to every day as you can
and be prepared to do it for quite a
while and whenever you have an
opportunity do it
and so i often talk about how i always
have my uh
mp3 player and now of course my iphone 6
plus which is a phenomenal device i have
mp3 files on there
i have my texts in in my in i link that
i can read so whenever i am stuck
anywhere
uh if i'm driving i'll listen
but if i'm sitting in a waiting room
somewhere i can read i can save words
and phrases i'm always with my language
because i know that in order to achieve
results it's that time with the language
i don't have to be talking to someone on
skype i don't have to be in the country
i can determine that i am going to at
every opportunity connect with the
language by putting first things first
because that's my goal it's only by
doing that that i'm going to
achieve that vision that i have of
myself speaking the language fluently so
uh stephen covey's advice is for a
manager or for a businessman but i think
it has equal application for language
learning
once you've determined where you want to
get to you have that vision that what he
calls the the mental creation
now it's the physical creation you gotta
make it happen so
do it
and that's the third of his habits of
highly effective people thanks for
listening